on va parler d'addiction réseaux sociaux
il me semble pour eux pour commencer un
phénomène qui touche tout le monde mais
surtout les jeunes moi en tout cas moi
ça peut me toucher je sais que quand
j'ai pas mon portable à côté de moi je
peux me sentir mal et ne pas avoir les
moments que quelque chose il y a un défi
qui est lancé par une association
pendant 10 jours pour débrancher les
jeunes des réseaux sociaux s'achète où
alors ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas que
les réseaux sociaux sur les écrans
général parce que ça touche ils essaient
de toucher tous les âges des des plus
petits jusqu'aux collégiens donc les
associations qui existent depuis 2017 à
Chatou elle s'appelle 10 jours pour voir
autrement alors pourquoi 10 jours pour
voir autrement parce qu'en fait c'est le
temps nécessaire pour se désintoxiquer
des écrans d'après les spécialistes
voilà alors cette association de de ces
gens de Chatou qui font partie de
l'enseignement du monde de
l'enseignement des parents d'élèves etc
propose à des à des jeunes à leur
famille à des plus petits de d'essayer
de réduire il y a pas d'interdit de
réduire la consommation d'écran pendant
10 jours et alors du coup on leur enlève
ça mais on leur propose autre chose à la
place parce que ça ça laisse un vide
parce qu'en fait il faut savoir que
l'enfant petit il joue puis un âge où il
joue plus trop qu'est-ce qu'il fait ben
hop il prend un écran il oublie qu'il
aime dessiner il oublie qu'il aime
construire je sais pas quoi faire de la
poterie voilà donc en fait il faut leur
esprit finalement oui puis les éléments
et leur proposer des activités
qui remplaceront donc l'écran de façon
bénéfique voilà donc bah ça marche très
bien ils ont des très bons retours il y
a par exemple ils ont proposé à
certaines enseignants de de donner tous
les soirs pendant 10 jours un petit top
bag à chaque enfant avec dedans une
petite activité à faire le soir mais
ludique évidemment alors même un truc
les règles du jeu de la bataille jouer
aux cartes je sais pas kit pour faire de
la pâte à sel faire des choses hyper
basiques qu'on fait on oublie et il y a
des collégiens même qui disent ah bah
oui j'avais oublié que j'aimais j'avais
oublié que j'aimais jouer du piano ou au
piano du piano les musiciens du merci
voilà donc ça c'est complètement gratuit
il y a eu donc pendant ces 10 jours
mieux vaut tard que jamais j'en parle
maintenant mais demain demain le 29 mars
ça va vous concerner aussi parce que ça
c'est Eric Desbois qui fait partie de
l'association qui est un professeur de
jazz les portes sont ouvertes
conservatoires et il faut venir aux
conservatoire de Château découvrir vous
allez peut-être me confirmer j'espère et
bien qu'il y a aussi des nouveaux
instruments il y a aussi de la zumba il
y a aussi je sais pas c'est dépoussiérer
vous êtes addict vous au smartphone ou
pas du tout puisque
ça concerne pas que enfin on est encore
jeune mais ça concerne pas que les
enfants donc tous les lundis j'ai mon
rapport hebdomadaire et quand tu vois
quand il me met que j'ai 4 heures 4h30
par jour d'écran en fait ça me fait une
petite ouais ça me fait une petite
blessure et puis après tu oublies et
puis on reprend
musique pratiquer un sport en tout cas
faites autre chose aussi pour s'aérer
agit toute et propose des la semaine de
l'écriture en janvier au secret des
cartes de vœux le la journée du jeu le
23 mai bon bref il faut regarder sur
leur site et surtout ils sont
complètement prêt à venir dans votre
école votre collège pour expliquer leur
travail expliquer comment faire et
s'aimer donner montrer l'exemple et voir
que ça marche et les jeunes même les
jeunes sont contents de de réaliser que
ils peuvent vivre sans écran et d'avoir
fait autre chose il y a une stimulation
entre eux quoi voilà une bonne nouvelle
à Rambouillet je sais que ça va vous
intéresser tout directement après la
fermeture du cinéma Vox est en 2019 les
habitants vont pouvoir bénéficier de
nouveau de séances de cinéma exactement
c'est en salle de spectacle la lanterne
qui on a donc dédié une salle la salle
Monique de Tilly un nom comme ça bref
vous la connaissez cet arbre merci et
qui va donc servir de de cinéma
provisoire voilà et il y aura donc
demain
après être allé au Conservatoire voilà
vous pouvez aller au cinéma à
Rambouillet le 29 mars donc demain ça
sera la première séance et vous aurez
trois deux à trois séances par jour les
mercredis vendredi samedi dimanche les
films arriveront une semaine après les
sorties officielles les films resteront
15 jours à l'affiche le tarif c'est
vraiment pas cher c'est 4,50 à 8 euros
qu'à 50 c'est pour les moins de 14 ans
voilà pour les mineurs et puis ces deux
rues de la Légion d'honneur et quoi
d'autre alors ça sera aussi ouvert en
juillet en août mais pas en juin
pourquoi parce qu'en juin les assauts
ont besoin de la place pour leur gala
voilà
de nouvelles séances ouais une petite
réaction si vous voulez alors on aura on
peut retrouver sur le site de
Rambouillet toute la programmation mais
allez-y quelques exemples
alors je verrai toujours au visage de
janeiry vous avez aussi sur le chemin
noir avec Jean Dujardin dont on a déjà
parlé et le lion et les trois brigands
un
voilà
je crois qu'on avait oublié de parler
des hérissons assez de ma faute du côté
vilaine-sur-seine heureusement que je
suis souple on va sauvegarder enfin en
tout cas on va tout faire pour
sauvegarder les
hérissons pour les
sauverables qui s'appelle vie comme
vilaine initiative et écologique voilà
c'était association elle écrit en 2014
par une dizaine du vilains une dizaine
voilà et en fait ce qui se passe et si
vous avez un projet écologique vous avez
envie de mettre en place à vilaine sur
scène vous allez les voir vous discutez
avec eux ils vont vous offrir un cadre
pour mettre en place votre action donc
là Monsieur Philippe Dupraz
est-ce que je vérifie si c'est bien ce
mot Philippe du Praz oui c'est bien
souvent fais-toi confiance fais-toi
confiance ma fille donc lui il a il en a
eu marre de voir tous ces petits animaux
morts sur les bords des routes et
principalement des hérissons donc il a
grâce à lui il va y avoir 12 panneaux
attention au ralentissez hérisson parce
que les hérissons sont
les animaux nocturnes se font énormément
écrabouiller et il faut savoir que c'est
le meilleur ami du jardinier c'est eux
qui vont manger vos limaces vos
escargots qui vont qui elles-mêmes
eux-mêmes dévorent salades Grégory et
donc on a besoin du réseau alors ce qui
est assez rigolo c'est quand on regarde
sur internet je parle vite parce que je
sens qu'on est non 3 minutes
alors quand on regarde sur internet
cette histoire de
Hérisson à vilaine-sur-seine il y a un
espèce d'organes un organisme union
internet pour la conservation de la
nature qui dit oh là là pas de risque de
disparition de des hérissons animal
après occupation mineur en revanche les
fouines et les blaireaux eux sont en
voie de disparition alors ok on va
protéger les fouilles et le bureau mais
en fait ce que m'a expliqué le monsieur
que j'ai eu au téléphone tout à l'heure
c'est que les hérissons dans certaines
régions sont en voie de disparition et
pas dans d'autres et puis on n'est pas
encore menacé d'invasion de Hérisson à
ce que je sache donc pourquoi pas les
protéger
si vous voulez organiser un potager en
permaculture chez vous enfin si vous
habitez bien sur ça bien évidemment ils
vont venir vous aider si vous n'avez pas
de jardin vous pouvez bénéficier du
jardin partagé
gnagnagna
j'ai oublié surtout des fois
allez-y allez-y très rapidement le
prochain c'est un écureuduc un écureude
bon peut-être que ça sera au menu de
votre d'une prochaine chronique les
insultes
tendre les deux fils entre deux arbres
le long d'une rue une route pour que les
écureuils passent
sur les insolites voilà c'est le cinéma
de vente en combo fin avec son bolitain
maintenant mais c'est le cinéma c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
manquait j'avais connu le Vox cinéma de
locaux moi j'ai grandi à Élancourt on
avait le ciné 7 qui est toujours ouverte
mais du coup c'était génial quand il y
avait des alternatives chouettes avec le
cratère Saint-Arnaud et mais c'est vrai
que la plupart aussi des grands films
c'était fallait aller jusqu'à 50 c'est
quelque chose qui est dommage pour une
ville qui pourrait je pense que c'est
une bonne manière de dynamiser la ville
en tout cas et de Rambouillet merci
Véronique vous revenez la semaine
prochaine insolites